[Music]
all right I know the men in this room
are going to enjoy this one what is it
about guns and dicks it's a man muscles
I thought it was a girl jump-roping RTD
poverty sure those are pretty to watch
well first of all have you heard this
rule that I've never heard of until this
this article here but that you should
not be wearing red to a wedding
no why you're not supposed wear white if
someone wears white see my [ __ ]
wedding yes I had heard about not
wearing white because the bride wears
white and I had also heard about not
wearing black because that's like your
signifying going to a funeral
I've never heard about red but
apparently red is another one of the
what country here I guess is it too sexy
because it stands out too much and like
you're you're removing attention from
the bride maybe the bride should try
harder
that's a stupid bride yeah cuz a Chinese
wedding isn't there a lot of red
everywhere lucky color yeah there's like
even the Dragons red yeah also in
Chinese weddings it isn't traditionally
like known to wear white right oh that's
true that's why and like red is like
more powerful or more standout and the
bride comes out in different outfits
like every hour if you do it like
traditionally they're like changing
every single so they come out of like 12
different outfits in crazy rich Asians
they recommend to wear red mm-hmm well
so this is a western wedding and so
there was this photo these photos posted
on the subreddit and they were pretty
much saying that this girl who wear this
dress was like this is like way too hot
for a wedding what do you guys I'll be
the judge of that it was a hot summer
day all right chill come on why are you
wearing full lace to my wedding I also
think red lace is really tacky
oh really tacky it's very Mindi's poor
no it's really yeah it looks like
tablecloth
it looks like super sexy and I don't
think it's wedding up home I think it's
wedding appropriate yeah it's porn
appropriate though
the color then or is it the lace it's
the way I think it's the case it's a
lace in the sea Thursday definitely for
me it's definitely less deep through
nests where I'm like do you leave like
this is a family event man for me it's
the stitching match whatever white heels
bro Oh cuz she needed to wear white cool
wedding too I don't know if I here's
another photo worth the bride what the
bride seems okay with it yeah like I
shouldn't be going to a wedding with
like underboob side boob showing like
yeah but they're on a pirate ship what
do you guys expect their [ __ ] wenches
punch that's right that makes sense
[Music]
maybe she's just very considerate of the
themes sure we did this all wrong guys
she's all like oh my friends gonna get
married on a pirate ship well [ __ ] it I
gotta be like a part of the ship then
you know there cuz even the bride's
dress doesn't look traditional wedding
you know has kind of like a different
yeah I don't think this is wedding
appropriate I mean like it's it's a cute
dress yeah yeah in black but I don't I
don't think you should wear that to a
wedding yeah I thought it was a little
much - wow the whole like under boo
thing is what really I think I like the
dress in a club and or like a lounge
environment or something I don't know
yeah like like a beach yeah like a
bougie-ass Beach Club kind of my
slut-shaming
I love [ __ ] clothes support hub Awards
this is perfect for that
yeah yeah and I think it's not even at
the porno there were even more like it's
true there were elegant when it was leg
Bend more covered up in this jail but
yeah it was a very interesting post on
Reddit but right now it to me it depends
on I would say like the crowd right cuz
for example right like imagine a bikers
wedding like who the [ __ ] cares about
classiness like everyone's going there
and you got your [ __ ] leather jackets
on and there's a theme right yeah Oh
everyone looks like it's accepted in
that group right so like in this
situation I'm
assume it like they got a pirate-themed
going on or even some lingerie themed
like yeah I mean look even though even
the bride she's she's got feathers
that's a pretty standard wedding dress
nowadays though with feathers it's
pretty standard for the style I'm
assuming that the style is like they're
all kind of like gaudy white people
because reminds me of like the whole
Jersey Shore like if everyone wants
Jersey Shore type on my I guess they all
fit together yeah you know I mean like
that's their style that's actually what
a lot of people were commenting it's
like well we can't fully judging it
without knowing what the wedding attire
code was like the dress yeah we saw was
this purely judged by like random people
online it wasn't even like a bride this
photo alone no it was just like posting
on a subreddit to like wedding shame
pretty much and then this was posted
they were like what the hell like that's
too crazy to wear for a wedding yeah but
you know some people love tacky [ __ ] you
know if the bride was cool with it I
mean I think that's the number one rule
for the wedding right she's forced to be
cool with it though it's just her being
like that doesn't mean that she's cool
what if she was ready like you maybe
that's like part of the uniform you know
there would be more pictures though
right yeah shame they wouldn't be like
oh look at all these they're like trying
to insult the one person right actually
that would be better that would be
better if you have the mentality of let
me shame this person if there was a
whole group of them yeah this that's
even more like it can you believe this
group would be okay no the big group
then you'd be like oh the bride made
this decision this would still tack you
know what if the whole bridesmaids look
like that even that's one person it's
still terror even if it's a whole group
it's still pretty [ __ ] tacky at the
end of it though it's not the worst
dress to [ __ ] where I would rather
[ __ ] where is this in a whole long
white lace scale you know like that's
when we fight but this is this is just
it's it's um it's this uncased
distasteful yeah what it is but in their
tastes it's amazing yeah I mean like if
this was a bunch of go-go dancing hos
wedding it makes sense that's what I'm
assuming though I don't want to say that
it could be I thought it was a hookers
ball but that's just kind of what
my mind you know like I don't mean the
bride's oh she doesn't look that crazy
compared to this chick so if it was that
like a hookers ball team like the bright
there have oh my god there are wedding
dresses
oh said are in same these days room
layoffs even one of the dresses I was
considering it was it was cut all the
way down here it was like wait why
didn't you go without showing it to you
know like there's too much your parents
are gonna be there either this is
alright you should have got one where
it's all see-through and you just use
those diamond fake diamond things you
know like how they have up to cover her
just to cover the nipple oh yeah yeah
she's pretty hot we're just white-hot
pasties like just heart pasties just for
love
it just has bells what were people
saying about in the comments about they
were saying okay so the actual caption
when they posted this this photo it red
hot wedding guests but talk about
stealing attention from the bride with
that sheer dress that's what I said it
does grab way more attention than the
bride's not good attention though it's
just if a lot of people were wearing
revealing clothes like that in bright
colors or whatever then it wouldn't be
taking attention cuz everyone's looking
this everyone right but that's why I
want to see the guests but if it's just
her then it's like you [ __ ] yeah well
one comment says someone is making a
statement with that dress if I had a
body like that I'd dress like that every
damn day however I feel like she's gotta
have some beef with the bride that dress
is way too hot for a wedding or some
people are just way too hot dress kind
of looks cold too
you know what the wind blowing on the
ship instead yeah it doesn't even look
like a sunny day she wasn't preparing
considered the wind chill vector I
should more planning have you seen like
wedding photos of the mother of the
bride wearing a long white dress yeah
there the Sun no it's always it's always
that this is my son complex Oh like
monster-in-law it was like that to
understand it yes but it was she
literally wore like a white gown not a
common thing that people do to like
fight like women who cannot lick over
some of you taking my son from me and
then like in every photo she's standing
next to the groom like like do you want
to [ __ ] your son or what hey do we have
any friends like that cuz I always hear
of guys that are like complete mama's
boys where their moms are also attached
to them with their umbilical cord might
be I wouldn't be surprised if they show
up in my mom tries to boss sudden get
her ass away from me oh you're not a
real mama's boy then you are not playing
the part of the mom my mom's trying to
[ __ ] yeah she's trying to assert the
relationship your mom's like try to hug
you in and you're doing this to her face
like get away yeah she's like if she's
just going like this just like they say
that if you if you ever have like
someone wearing a white dress at your
wedding a good bridesmaid would
accidentally spill wine on her dress
yeah there's so many weddings oh honey
very catty whoa I'm down I'll do it
that's a good drama see that's that's
one of the reasons why I like weddings
is like I want to watch some [ __ ] go
down but it never goes down it's just
good food yeah do you like watching the
Hmong wedding brawls rumbles like I
don't know I guess like people from
rival like gangs show up dude you're
fighting yeah like straight up chairs
[ __ ] hole compilation waiting brawls
do you ever think about your wedding I'm
like what you would want to wear yeah
surprisingly though like um contrary to
or like it's completely opposite of my
birthday I actually want just a small
like I would I'd be happy with the
wedding at the what is it the courthouse
that's all I really want cuz I mean it's
not I don't really care I'm not the type
of person that cares about the wedding
no but you know we just want to get
married yeah yeah that's what I want to
do I wanted a eloping heels like no we
have to have all I don't I just didn't
want to like go through it then and then
ten years down the road like regret like
oh we should have had a bigger wedding
here so that's true I mean that's why I
agreed to cuz I'm like you're right I do
regret like not going to prom or
whatever so I'm like yeah wedding yeah
can't you're like redo it or just not
the same once you read I would do
something like it's very words would be
something it'd be something small more
intimate I don't want the [ __ ] Asian
wedding with five hundred aunties and
uncles that I don't know it's tiring to
these you're already stressed out about
like the the mechanics of the wedding
itself and then looking the part or
whatever and then needing to deal with
the the the overbearing family yes
destination wedding you weed out a lot
of people I wish I had a billion bucks
so I could have a wedding and then the
only way to get into the venue is just
like 200 lines of TSA like way before
Hannah my auntie that uncle I don't like
so when they're scanning their purse
just keep finding [ __ ] like a minimum
gift requirement only hundred dollars no
no no go to the bank there's an ATM here
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]